[Music]
foreign
good evening then from Nottingham a city
in shock tonight after a series of
violent attacks left three people dead
and others injured police here say they
are keeping an open mind over the motive
for The Killing Spree
it All Began just before 4am this
morning when officers were called here
to ilkeston Road when two 19 year olds
were found dead in the street
then news of another crime on Milton
Street a mile away three people were
injured after a driver tried to run them
over
a short time afterwards a 50 year old
man was found dead in magdala Road
that's about one and a half miles away
then Police Stopped a van on Maple
Street where they tasered and then
arrested a 31 year old man on suspicion
of murder
well we now know that two of the victims
attended Nottingham University will
bring you more on how the violence has
affected the large student population
here and the city at large but first
Sky's National correspondent Tom
Parmenter has tonight's first report
still scattered on the floor the
suspect's cap bag and jacket he'd just
been pulled out of this van at gunpoint
there were bullet holes in the
windscreen of the vehicle but the
suspect was dragged out alive I heard
the police straight away and as soon as
I heard it I came to the window and then
I then saw everything like I saw them
like draw their guns or whatever they
had at him I saw them drag him out he
seem to be complying with them no they
dragged him out he wasn't really
complaining stopping him was the
priority after three people had been
killed and three others were in hospital
that moment brought this violent spree
across this city to an end the 31 year
old was taken into custody arrested on
suspicion of murder 19 year old Barnaby
Weber from Somerset was one of those
stabbed to death on ilkeston road at 4am
where a night out partying had been
drawing to an end
he was a keen cricketer his Club
Bishop's hole near Taunton said he was a
key part of their success playing over
30 games and scoring 622 runs
friends in Nottingham placed a cricket
shirt and cap among the flowers in Saint
Peter's Church
there were tributes to to another 19
year old called Grace who'd been on a
night out with Mr Weber
after the stabbings the suspect drove
the white van into the city center past
the theater Royal where he hit three
pedestrians one is critically injured in
hospital
the third victim a man in his 50s was
found dead here on magdala Road
forensic searches got underway armed
police were back on ilkeston road
smashing their way into this terraced
house as their investigation moved at
PACE we are still in the early stages of
the investigation and need to determine
exactly what the motives were behind
this attack we are keeping an open mind
and are working closely with
counter-terrorism policing to establish
the facts
take days to establish the motive the
forensic searches finding every witness
or piece of CCTV
several properties remain cordoned off
and for now it is a murder inquiry led
by Nottinghamshire police
this city stands together
and waits for an explanation
Tom Parmenter Sky News Nottingham
well this part of the city is well used
to a vibrant nightlife students at
Nottingham University should tonight
have been attending their graduation
ball instead many of them attended a
vigil in memory of those killed Becky
Johnson has this report
in the darkest of times they came to
light candles the shock on young faces
friends left in disbelief that two of
their fellow students are among the Dead
between the flowers a cricket cap left
it a vigil to remember the lives so
suddenly cut short
literally hundreds of of people poured
in and out of this church here in the
center of a city that's been filled with
grief and shock today and and you could
sense that palpably here many young
people many students who who came here
to to
just to be in it and do something today
when when they've they've kind of felt
an overwhelming sense of of loss
students are living just yards from
where their friends were stabbed the
road where they were attacked is a
well-trodden route back after nights out
in the city center the fear among
students is it could have been anyone I
was going to go home on Saturday but I'm
just I just picked my train ticket I'm
gonna go tomorrow like I know it's not
like a normal thing that happens here
but it's still a bit stressful so I'm
just gonna just go home this young
vibrant part of the city has felt eerily
quiet as police cordons block off
streets that should have been full of
students out enjoying the Sun at the end
of term
with large parts of the city affected
the atmosphere here has been tense the
main question is why anyone would do
this
across Nottingham police continue their
work to find answers for the victims and
their loved ones
thoughts and prayers are just with their
families as as a parent you just can't
imagine that
phone call from the police to them to
tell them that they're as we now know
young people students
just 19 years old are not coming home
again
it is that horror that's haunting this
city but people here are determined to
join together to try to find strength in
each other Becky Johnson Sky News
Nottingham
good evening from Miami where Donald
Trump today became the most high profile
person to ever face charges under
America's Espionage Act he appeared in
the court behind me accused of risking
National Security by removing highly
classified documents about the United
States weapons programs and the
country's defense vulnerabilities and
storing them in the ballroom of his
Mar-A-Lago Resort after he pled not
guilty and departed Court he made an
impromptu stop at a local Cuban Cafe on
route to yet another fundraising event a
U.S correspondent Mark Stone has our
first report
the first glimpse of a president on the
day he went to court Mr Trump
no answer to the question which has
brought Donald Trump to this moment in
U.S history
at his Golf Club outside Miami and with
his legal team America's 45th president
was about to be the first to be charged
under the Espionage Act
president Trump how are you feeling
great he says and then into the armored
vehicle for the Convoy to court
[Music]
[Applause]
a slow drive-by outside the resort and
as every second of this was captured he
was on his own social media site Witch
Hunt he posted
at court the crowds had swelled for a
spectacle that we wouldn't see
away from the cameras on the 13th floor
in courtroom number three president
Trump along with his aide Walt router
surrendered themselves to the duty
magistrate they were under arrest on
federal charges
[Music]
outside one of the president's lawyers
was commanding the Airways owning the
moment and with more than a hint of the
way Mr Trump wants this to play out
the decision to pursue charges against
Blind Eye to others is emblematic of the
corruption that we have here
we are at a turning point in our
nation's history the truth is that the
cases she mentions against Joe Biden and
others are under investigation
out Trump but if the aim is to pit the
people against the institutions that are
supposed to hold the country together
well then his National support base is
certainly strong enough to deepen the
division
he was in the courthouse for almost
exactly an hour he sat stone-faced and
it was left for his lawyer to say we
most certainly plead not guilty
then as the Convoy left this
he is an anti-trump protester
and he was quickly arrested
will one man detained here but this is
just as an attention that the authority
will be worried about
[Applause]
and then this day of spectacles moved on
to the city's most famous Cuban Cafe and
a photo opportunity
and prompt you on the face of it
and of course and it was President Trump
who had the last word I think it's a rig
deal here
we have a country that's got
no we have a country that's got nothing
but problems
he'll head now to New Jersey his golf
course there and a news conference later
Mark Stone Sky News in Miami
so that then the start of one of the
most consequential prosecutions this
country has ever seen that Donald Trump
could still become president even after
he's charged with Espionage as a quirk
of America's legal system he's become a
symbol of this divided country his
supporters back him without question his
detractors are resigned to his political
impunity our International correspondent
John Sparks has been hearing both sides
of the argument
there are places in Miami where people
go to let their hair down
acts of Escape when confrontation Comes
To Town
but the prosecution of Donald Trump
won't change their world you just look
at the past couple years nothing changed
people's you know
so why would this be any different I'm
happy that he is actually being indicted
for crimes he probably committed okay I
mean there's evidence he committed them
so
I just didn't think it was ever going to
happen
the prosecution of the former president
has shocked many in Florida the state
votes Republican and it votes for Donald
Trump and there are those who think the
government is out to get him
but on Ocean Drive
people see things in a different way
at the world famous Palace drag show
people say the former president doesn't
speak to and hasn't spoken up for them
what do you make of Donald Trump
we have we have someone that is against
our community and as you can see we are
we are not hurting anybody and we are
about love and we are not accepted and
we just want to be here and live life
the way
not everybody wants to live their lives
fully
[Music]
[Applause]
90 minutes up the road we found
different performers on a very different
stage this event hosted by club 47 part
of Donald Trump's so-called base
and the featured speaker aspiring office
holder Kerry Lake
Trump is a warrior
a warrior
he's Godzilla
and they're just little tiny geckos
running around
Trump's indictment the product of Joe
Biden's fearful regime she said and we
didn't see anyone objecting I
need Donald J Trump
room his shower room his bedroom other
rooms it doesn't play well
before Joe Biden
either if the former presidents made
mistakes the Democrats have done worse
and the Republicans of Florida well they
have a nation to save John Sparks Sky
News Miami Beach
well our us correspondent Mark stone is
here with me quite a day Mark and now a
trial awaits a former president who who
faces charges that he risks National
Security but could still end up in the
White House yeah it's it's a truly
remarkable uh moment and right or wrong
and the country is so split we do now
face the prospect of the trial of course
there will be legal arguments um his
defense will try and find ways to to
throw this out of court they will also
do everything that they can to delay
that is a classic tactic of Donald Trump
we've seen it in his other court cases
and there are many uh he tries to delay
and he will try and do that to take this
into the election campaign beyond the
election campaign possibly but this is
without question I think the most
consequential and the most watched
prosecution in U.S history forget
Watergate that never went to trial that
was an impeachment it wasn't a trial
this is absolutely huge in the immediate
term uh right now he's in the air he's
on his way up to his Bedminster Golf
Course where he was that day last week
seems like ages ago when the indictment
dropped when it was unsealed when we all
saw what he is alleged to have done he
was playing golf then I imagine he'll be
playing golf there tomorrow but first of
all later tonight he will be on the
airwaves owning the moment once again
talking to his supporters talking to the
country he hopes to present his
Narrative of what he thinks happened it
will be like it was here divisive stuff
I would think Mark Stone thank you and
then celebrating his 77th birthday
tomorrow as well yes full coverage of
the final part of Trump's day if you
like when he will be making those
remarks up in Bedminster 8 15 local time
1 15 in the morning UK time we'll have
full coverage of that for now let's head
back to Sally for more of the day's news
in London
Anna thank you good evening death misery
and incalculable loss the impact of
coronavirus as described by the lead
Council to the public inquiry which
began hearing evidence today
outside a dignified vigil of bereaved
family members held a silent protest
demanding to know whether their loved
one's death could have been averted if
the UK had been better prepared for a
pandemic our home editor Jason Farrell
has been hearing from some of them
Coleman Mariana eels Mira what sets this
inquiry apart Louise Healey is that it
examines events that have hugely
impacted each and every one of us
William Roy Edwards but some families
more than others
Kim Nutt lost her husband to covid
ambulance driver Paul Paul Nutt
the girls my other daughter as well
begged him not to go to work because
they were worried about his safety and
he said the guidance says what I have to
do and I'll adhere to it and I'll be
safe
and it really wasn't God this was wrong
the guidance was totally wrong
at that time Paul was told he didn't
need to wear a mask it was the
testimonies of families that opened the
inquiry with a video played to the room
I said can you try and
call us then if you know you can leave
this time to get us up there we don't
want to die alone she was only 54.
and she died alone
five days after my third
the scope of this inquiry is immense
from the political decisions that were
made when the virus arrived to the
long-term impact on the Health Service
but this first round of evidence looks
at whether we could and should have been
better prepared even at this stage
before hearing the evidence
it is apparent that we might not have
been very well prepared at all the
council to the inquiry told the chair
lady Hallett that previous
administrations may have fallen short
following the Ebola outbreak it was
right that the G7 devoted significant
time to how best to try and prevent a
future Global pandemic
that despite this pledge from David
Cameron there was a failure to consider
the need for Mass testing or how to
protect the vulnerable there was a
blinkered focus on the likelihood of a
flu pandemic and anyway resilience plans
were consumed by preparations for brexit
the families expect the evidence will
show a lack of responsibility in
government for civil emergency
preparedness with little or no
ministerial leadership and a chaos of
committees which led to poor planning
and ultimately a reactive rather than
proactive response to the virus and the
association of directors of Public
Health confirmed it was chaotic at the
start of the pandemic directors were
learning about new policies and guidance
at the same time as members of the
public were when the televised 5 PM
daily briefings began to be broadcast
these are the details families want to
know what do you want to come out of
this inquiry the truth and what actually
happened we need to know about the
decisions that were made why they were
made or why they weren't made so that we
can hopefully learn the lessons to
prevent anything like this happening
again inquiry is expected to last more
than three years Jason Farrell Sky News
before his death nine-year-old Alfie
Steele was beaten dunked in cold water
while naked and locked outside in the
middle of the night his neighbors
repeatedly called the emergency services
to report his screams he had more than
50 injuries when he died today his
mother and her partner were convicted
over his death after months of abuse Dan
Whitehead has been following the case
and a warning his report contains
details of Alfie's abuse
she was trying to explain away his
injuries
her lies had begun when she called 999.
ambulance services the patient breathing
the truth is nine-year-old Alfie Steele
had been repeatedly beaten and then held
under a cold bath as part of an ongoing
regime of punishment he had more than 50
injuries and showed signs he'd been
deprived of oxygen
as his mother pretended she didn't know
where her fiance was
[Music]
Dirk Howell was running away from the
house the police caught him as he tried
to get on a train he answered for me so
so at the moment
she under arrest
Alfie had suffered over a year of abuse
there were times he was locked outside
the house in droitwich in Worcestershire
a neighbor recorded his desperate
screams to be let in
[Music]
neighbors were so concerned they
repeatedly called 999 this was April
2020. I'm hearing some really worrying
noises from next door I've heard what
sounds like a child in distress and this
a month later
God and disciplining him he's standing
like a statue the elephants have to
report them before yes
this lab we believe is called Alfred
then most significantly this in August
police emergency hello it sounds like my
neighbors and doing something bad to
their kid in the back like they're
really hurting them that was six months
before Alfie's death
police had put in place a protection
plan that meant Dirk Howell wasn't
allowed to stay overnight a rule the
couple repeatedly flouted
Alfie's removal from Carla Scott was
discussed in a year before his death in
yet another case where a child known to
authorities has died
an independent child safeguarding review
is underway but any lessons will come
too late for Alfie
dumb waited Sky News
two South Wales police officers are
being investigated for gross misconduct
in relation to the deaths of two teenage
boys which sparked the Ely riots in
Cardiff last month the independent
office for police conduct said a notice
had been served to the driver and
passenger in a police van seen driving
behind the boys in the Ely area of the
city the deaths of 16 year old Charisse
Sullivan and 15 year old Harvey Evans
led to riots in the local area
Boris Johnson has asked the commons
privileges committee to publish its
report into whether he lied to
Parliament without further delay Mr
Johnson said he wanted to let the world
judge their nonsense with the report not
expected to be released until later this
week
the trial of Connor Chapman the man
accused of killing Ellie Edwards outside
a pub in wallacy on Christmas Eve has
begun at Liverpool Crown Court the jury
was shown graphic CCTV footage of a man
firing 12 shots injuring five people and
fatally wounding the 26 year old who was
enjoying a night out with friends
now you would have thought that
paychecks growing at their fastest rate
for 20 years would be good news well it
is for employees but not for the economy
Bank of England Governor Andrew Bailey
today reiterated his concerns over how
Rising wages Stoke what's described as
core inflation that's the rate at which
prices rise once energy and food costs
are stripped out here's our business
correspondent Paul Kelsey
the prize ingredient in a restaurant
kitchen these days the people Britain
has a shortage of workers and it's hit
Hospitality hard
the Oakman group employs 1600 people in
40 venues but recruiting and retaining
them comes at a price
since brexit it's got a lot harder again
there have been shortages across my
industry our Energy bill has got up by
about 70 our labor cost by 20 odd
percent food and drink by you know food
in particular probably 20 plus drink a
bit lower
um but we've only been able to achieve
about an eight percent increase in in
our prices so profits are being squeezed
and we need a way out of it with more
than a million vacancies unfilled across
the country competition for staff is
forcing up pay in the three months to
April wages were 7.2 percent higher than
a year ago the fastest increase outside
the pandemic but that's still less than
CPI inflation running at 8.7 percent
which means real wages the spending
power of the pound in your pocket
actually fell 2.3 percent there are
fewer people working since covid too
some through early retirement but record
numbers through long-term sickness
further squeezing the market Rising
wages is good news for workers these
figures include an increase in the
minimum wage but they can indicate
trouble for the economy because they
suggest that inflation is becoming
ingrained and that makes it more likely
the bank of England will again increase
interest rates next week and that will
raise the cost of borrowing for everyone
financial markets now think an increase
is inevitable right this morning's
numbers Illustrated we've got a very
tight labor market in this country we've
we've apply of Labor
which is showing signs of recovering but
it's very slowly frankly we still think
the rate of inflation is going to come
down but it's taking a lot longer
than we expected the tight labor market
may be fueling inflation and restricting
growth and the price of some government
borrowing has exceeded even the chaos of
Lids trusses mini budget not a recipe
for short-term success Paul says Sky
News in Woburn
and welcome back to uh Nottingham at the
end of one of this City's Darkest Days
in the early hours of this morning an
armed attacker stabbed two students here
then stole a van killed its owner and
attempted to mow down members of the
public our crime correspondent Martin
brunt is with me here first of all let's
talk about what we do know and that is
that several families are grieving
tonight yes we've had throughout the day
three statements from the police each
has added a bit more information
particularly about the victims not too
much detail but we do know that one of
them is Barnaby weather one of them 19
year old students who was stabbed to
death walking back the mile and a half
from the city center to his
accommodation near here we don't know
yet the identity of the young woman who
was with him but bits of the pictures
are beginning to be put together and
what we don't know frustratingly is any
idea of a motive no initially of course
everybody thought this is a potential
terror attack I think as the day has
gone on that's receded it appears
tonight to be a very much the focus on
criminality of some description but if
it wasn't a terror attack and there were
CT counter-terror officers here today
their role seems to have been diminished
tonight if it wasn't a terror attack
what on Earth was it that possessed a
man to go on the Rampage three separate
attacks leaving three people dead and
three people injured one of them tonight
critically and in hospital
okay Martin thanks very much indeed and
yes it has been a truly awful day here
and everyone you meet in the street
everyone you talk to does have that one
question that Martin posed then and that
question is why
Sally back to you in London
mark thank you well that was Sky News at
10 coming up we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's papers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
Guardian about those fatal attacks in
Nottingham their headline students among
victims stabbed to death in Nottingham
rampage that story leading a lot of
tomorrow's front pages and tonight we're
joined by Sonia soda the chief leader
writer at The Observer and Henry Hill
the deputy editor of conservative home
will be speaking to them very shortly
see you after this short break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
this is Sky News in just a moment the
Press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive but first
our top stories two 19 year old students
and a man in his 50s was stabbed to
death in Nottingham while three other
people were injured when the alleged
attacker tried to run them over in a van
stolen from one of the victims
Donald Trump has pleaded not guilty to
37 felony counts relating to the
mishandling of confidential documents
and obstruction of justice at a court
hearing in Miami
and the covid-19 inquiry has held its
first public hearings with back with
chairwoman baroness Hallett promising to
put the suffering of victims at the
heart of the inquiry
[Music]
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
Sonia soda the chief leader writer at
The Observer and Henry Hill the deputy
editor of conservative home they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight we'll speak to them very
shortly but first let's have a look at
what's on some of those front pages
the guardian leads with the attack in
Nottingham in which three people were
killed
the Metro also leading on the attack
calling it a white van knife horror
the attacks in Nottingham Nottingham
also on the front of the Daily Mail
the Stars headline Killers Rampage
and the sun also caused the attack a
rampage
the Ft leads with the governor of the
bank of England's words that inflation
is taking a lot longer than hoped to
come down
while the eye says mortgage level stress
is to hit levels last seen in the 1980s
reminded that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you're watching
us
and we're joined tonight by Sonia soda
and Henry Hill so let's get started
shall we very good evening to you both
thanks so much
for joining us
um a very somber press preview looking
ahead to tomorrow's front pages at the
majority of them leading on the horrific
scenes in Nottingham today Sonia your
take on all of this to start with
uh yes so absolutely terrible scenes
unfolded in Nottingham today
um there's still a lot that's unclear
about what happened overnight but what
we do know is that two students both age
19 uh were stabbed to death
um by a 30 well there's a 31 year old um
suspect involved and a man in his 50s
was also killed and police suspect that
he was the owner of the white van
um that the suspected killer used to
drive around after
um
as well as the deaths of the two 19 year
olds uh the van was driven again the
police think it was the same suspect
um uh into some people
um they are okay I think I think it was
two people so there's still a lot that
we simply don't know yet we know that
this was a 31 year old suspect there's
absolutely no information yeah about
what is potential motivations might be
we know that the counter-terrorism
police have been involved but the police
say that that is normal with an incident
of this scale where they're making so
many um inquiries
um it's obviously absolutely devastating
for the families of the two students
who've lost their lives and their
friends uh their friends in in
Nottingham and for the whole student
community in Nottingham but I think
there's a lot that we still don't know
here yet yeah absolutely and Henry you
know
there's no words to describe really how
terrible this is to teenagers on their
way home from a night out and then you
know stabbed to death but of course the
big question hanging over people in
Nottingham is why
yes it is and we simply don't know you
know this is an ongoing and active
police investigation uh this the the
suspect was only taken into custody
today and there is a natural tendency to
fill that kind of void with speculation
but I think it's it's important that
yeah we will know we will find out the
police will release the information in
due time and we will have those answers
for the moment I think it's important
one you know that we make sure that you
know as the police will surely be doing
that there are no further attacks and
that everybody is safe and then it is
important that we take the time to wait
for the facts to emerge that we don't
rush to any conclusions or judgments and
that can be difficult when we don't
where we have that void of information
because we naturally want to talk about
something of this magnitude and we need
to fill that space with something but
nothing good ever comes of doing that so
we will find out in due time but at for
the moment we simply don't know why this
happened yeah absolutely police say they
are keeping an open mind when it comes
to the motive and so yeah I mean there's
not huge a huge amount of variety in
terms of what's on the front pages
tomorrow but we're just going to mention
the front page of the sun now
um which has the photographs of the two
teenagers who who they say were killed
in Nottingham
that's right um and as you said it was
you know two 19 year olds on the way
home from a night out at 4am
um so it's a total tragedy and as you
would expect this is a major national
incident it's been dominating news
coverage all day so you really would
expect it to be on on the vast majority
of front pages
um which it is
yeah absolutely every parent's worst
nightmare let's move on to the financial
times Henry of course one of the other
big stories today is the covert inquiry
which kicked off
yeah absolutely so this is Dame Heather
highlights inquiry which you know may be
familiar to viewers from The Rail
between it and the cabinet office about
the release of Boris Johnson's texts
which due to the pace of events already
feels like it took place months ago but
in fact I my my diary reminds me was in
fact relatively recent and this is the
comprehensive investigation into what
went wrong with the or indeed Right In
fairness with the government's covered
response it wants to investigate what
lessons we can learn whether the United
Kingdom was prepared and what uh good or
bad steps were taken during that process
now it's going to take its mooted to
take three years to complete we don't I
don't think we're certain that it will
take that long some of these judge-led
inquiries have taken an awful lot longer
to get to the truth uh so I think there
is a tension there and this is one of
the problems with the way that we run
public inquiries in this country is that
there is a tension between two of the
objectives of the inquiry the first is
we want to find out what happened with
the with the covid response as quickly
as possible so we can learn lessons and
the other is that we want to get really
down into the guts of it so that we and
find out who made bad decisions assign
blame give some catharsis and closure to
those who were affected by the pandemic
and lost loved ones now the first of
those objectives would be better served
by a much faster inquiry a sort of an
inquisitorial
inquiry that maybe took evidence on a
no-blame basis on a black box basis that
wasn't published and that could get to
the lessons really quickly so we could
apply them and then this other process
could be conducted separately and it
could take more time to go into those
granular details but at present we're
lumping both of those together into one
and so it we are going to take longer to
get to some of those answers about
pandemic preparedness stuff and I think
it would probably be ideal
yeah and Sonya it was really interesting
wasn't it the the lead Council of the
inquiry had some very interesting
comments to make uh on this today in the
inquiry opening in terms of the lack of
preparedness for a covid
um pandemic and and the fact that the
country was distracted by dealing with
brexit
yeah so this is the Barrister advices
the um inquiry and I think we're going
to be hearing a mix of things that sound
quite familiar to us as the inquiry goes
on and stuff um that is new but this is
the first day and the first stage of the
inquiry will be looking at preparedness
and there's already been a lot of
discussion about preparedness
um there's been Revelations about X
exercises that took place in Whitehall
for example in preparation for a flu
pandemic where recommendations and
findings were not acted upon
um so I but I think there's going to be
more that emerges
um through the course of the inquiry and
it's obviously been um you know in the
news in recent days and weeks because
there is this legal battle between the
government and between the inquiry
itself in terms of what material the
government has to hand over and what
whether it's the government who gets to
decide what's relevant or whether it's a
judge into in charge who gets to decide
what's in the public interest and what
should be released to the public
um you know so so that that those legal
wrangles May yet delay things more
um I agree with I mean I think it's very
important that there is this statutory
inquiry that's led by a judge where she
does have the power to summon Witnesses
where she does have the power to demand
documents I think that's in incredibly
important but I also think that actually
we could have probably done the sort of
more rapid review that Harry's talks
about to be honest I think we could have
done that by now and indeed a country
like Sweden has already published um
their report I've looked at some of the
findings from that for example and so I
think you know optimally we would have
got the got the sort of Rapid review uh
with lessons for what we need to do
differently if you know if I hope this
won't happen of course but if another
pandemic were to sort of drop on our
door in the next couple of years
um you know to have those lessons ready
and waiting but I do think that the
statutory nature of this inquiry is
really really important and you do need
that thoroughness as well and Henry of
course at the center of this inquiry are
the bereaved families but there is also
a sideshow in terms of Boris Johnson and
his dispute with the cabinet office over
you know releasing material to the
inquiry
yeah absolutely so this is an ongoing
dispute basically the uh Dame Dame
Heather Hallett the judge leading the
inquiry has requested that all of Boris
Johnson's WhatsApp messages with 40 key
members of the government be handed over
to the inquiry so that they can be
reviewed at anything relevant can be
included in the inquiries remit now the
dispute from the cabinet office is the
cabinet office is wanting to hand over
redacted versions because they say Well
they're happy to hand over anything
relevant uh the WhatsApp exchanges
contain all sorts of information which
might not just be irrelevant but might
also be personal uh and therefore it
should be improper to hand that over now
I believe the cabinet office is going to
take that to court it will be very
interesting to see whether or not they
win I think that you know so James e d a
very senior lawyer who works for the
government argues that it's essential
for protecting the principle of uh uh
free cabinet debate and private cabinet
debate he's a better lawyer than me but
I don't know whether that's going to
hold water but it really highlights I
think the tension between the fact that
all of the law covering this stuff is
old right the the inquiries are updates
back 2005 the public records act are
much older than that the Freedom of
Information Act dates back to I think
2001 and all of that predates WhatsApp
and it predates the age when politicians
advisors and officials would add
something like what where they were
simultaneously conducting official
business personal business private
business and all the rest of it so I
suspect that the the cabinet's office
will end up having to hand over
everything it's sort of Dame Heather's
threatening to publish it all she and
her team simply wish to go through it I
think that's going to be a very high
argument to resist but it does highlight
the fact that we need to bring the law
governing public records and public
information up to date so that we don't
have this kind of dispute in future and
it's clear what the status of WhatsApp
messages and so on are when a judge
comes knocking at the door yeah
certainly it seems very unclear as
things stand Henry uh Sonia will give
you a little break more to discuss
coming up more of our papers more of our
pay-per-view including coverage a former
president Donald Trump's court case in
Miami as seen here in the guardian we'll
be talking about that next
[Music]
if there's a journey that could be done
in two and a half hours or less by train
but also has an air route available uh
then the idea is that you can't do that
train anymore well actually we're saying
in the UK it's all about choosing the
right mode for the right journey and in
some cases people will choose the train
typically if you can do city-centered
City Center in less than three hours but
actually many of our Journeys in the UK
take longer than that actually sixty
percent of our air routes are over water
which many people wouldn't realize you
know Scottish islands Channel Islands
Northern Ireland and so on uh so really
what we're focused on is what's the
solution to take the carbon out of
flying uh so that we can still continue
to enjoy the benefits of domestic air
travel in future and that's through a
mix of efficiencies but particularly
sustainable Aviation fuels and hydrogen
in future well I mean if it was here it
would be nothing short of a disaster
with our current rail Services frankly
um and and I think consumer confidence
is a really big issue for this
internationally so
um you know as Matt says we actually
don't have rail set services to to
as an alternative to a lot of our rail
our flights but
um but actually even if there were and I
was traveling for business or I had a
connection to get or I had an event to
be at would I trust a train
um service absolutely not what France
has done is a start and it's got people
thinking about it but for it to do it
successfully it would have to be as Matt
says a more International approach and I
think for UK consumers there's a big
confidence issue the UK sector was the
first in the world to commit to Net Zero
we did that just before the pandemic and
actually the whole of the global
industry and all of the world's
governments have now made that same
commitment there are three 2050 which is
the goal we're all aiming at three big
things that are going to get us there in
aviation more efficient aircraft and
operations modernizing airspace is part
of that lighter planes more efficient
engines that helps but it doesn't get
you to Nets here are the two big big
unlocks for us the one biggest one is
sustainable Aviation fuels these are
drop-in fuels you can use them in
today's planes and they cut carbon by 70
or more from current operations but
there's also an exciting opportunity for
hydrogen planes completely zero emission
planes for shortage earners in future
and the really exciting thing actually
is we're talking about domestic travel
in the UK is that those hydrogen
aircraft are going to be most suited to
Shorter routes smaller aircraft sizes
and shorter routes so we expect them to
first come on on some of the domestic
routes that we're talking about
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview with me now Sonia soda the chief
leader writer at The Observer and Henry
Hill the deputy editor of conservative
home and Sonia T first front page of
your paper and like many also covering
Donald Trump's historic court appearance
extraordinary obviously he's pleaded not
guilty to all of these charges but even
if convicted it won't necessarily stop
him from returning to the White House
no and that's just kind of quite a crazy
thing to say isn't it so it's a huge
story Donald Trump is facing 37 charges
of concealing classified documents from
federal officials he appeared in a Miami
courtroom today
um and you know if he's found guilty of
these charges he could even end up in
prison for decades
um but that doesn't officially count him
out of running for the presidency now
you might expect that a president
um you know charged with these crimes
very very serious crimes uh facing uh
trial facing a grand jury that that in
the court of public opinion might
prevent him from running for the
presidency again but the issue is of
course that America is hugely divided
his very loyalist voters
um don't don't believe that you know
he's guilty of these these charges
obviously that's yet to be determined
um and he is portraying this as a Witch
Hunt to his supporters now that's a
familiar refrain to us here in the UK
because Boris Johnson has also been
using that term in relation to the
privilege privileges committee report
whether he must let Parliament which
we'll be talking about later but um yes
it's it's you know he says it's a a
Witch Hunt that these charges are jumped
up and there are lots of people in
America who believe that so incredible
though it may sound he may still yet end
up running for uh the presidency again
even with these charges hanging over him
and Henry uh Boris Johnson still
dominating many headlines as well he's
he's urging uh tonight uh the Privileges
committee to publish their report and
many of them are predicting uh quite how
damning they could be it could be for
him
yeah well I mean it's good of him to
urge them to publish it but if they were
going to publish it anyway uh and as far
as I'm aware they're going to publish it
tomorrow anyway but yes absolutely we
haven't seen the Privileges report yet
but we can infer a lot from it from the
way Boris Johnson has responded to it he
was given Advanced side of it on Friday
uh and he chose to resign from parlor
which tells you I think an awful lot
about what it's going to say now the the
way this works is that effect
effectively the Privileges committee
which is a cross-party committee of MPS
which actually has a conservative
majority although it's chaired by a
labor MP have been investigating the
allegation of whether or not Boris
Johnson misled the House of Commons they
will recommend a sanction to the House
of Commons and the whole House of
Commons which again remember has a big
conservative majority has to vote on it
and if they vote to suspend him for more
than 10 days then he is subject to
what's called a recall petition a recall
petition means that uh 10 percent of the
voters in his constituency can sign a
petition to have a by-election now
that's important to understand because
essentially what what this is when he's
when he's allergic to witch Hunters he
is and when he's calling the the
committee a kangaroo court think about
what the logic of that actually is it
means that a committee which has a
conservative majority including a
long-standing brexiteer and Tori MP from
the red wall has has chosen to go for
Boris Johnson that they will make
recommendations which the House of
Commons which has a conservative
majority which he delivered not three
years ago will then vote for that then
the 10 of his constituents will choose
to have a recall a referendum a recall
petition and then that he would lose the
by-election yeah that's the allegation
that that chain of events is what
Johnson is clinging is a Witch Hunt
against him it's absurd I forget how
much she loved the detail Henry we're
gonna have to move on with a slightly
short of time Sonia just a brief thought
from you about the front page of the eye
um just so many people concerned about
their mortgages with interest rates set
to rise
yeah this is going to be a really
worrying front page for so many people
so uh interest rates are now forecast to
increase to
5.75 by the end of 2023 which means that
we'll see mortgage rates upwards of six
percent so millions of people with fixed
rate mortgages uh ending in the next two
three months who are going to have to
try and re-fix at these new higher rates
that's going to add a huge amount onto
people's monthly repayments at a time
when the cost of living is going up food
and energy costs are higher so um I
think it's a really worrying time for
people yeah absolutely certainly a huge
concern for so many households Sonja
Henry thank you so much lots more to
talk about in the next hour we'll give
you a little bit of a break thanks very
much indeed do stay with us coming up
next on Sky News at 11. we'll have more
on the three people killed and the other
three injured in a terrifying early
morning attack in him but police rule
out terrorism we'll have all the latest
on that incident at the top of the hour